if you had to clash swords with
terrifying Pirates Dodge cannonballs by
Marine Sailors and save a village from
fish manned creatures what would you do
no need to bring your squad back
together first even have a chance of
finding the one-piece treasure alive I'm
going to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to beat the
fish man monsters in one piece part two
this kid here will watch hundreds of
innocent people die Luffy and his crew
here plus one mystery present that they
need to recruit Sanji are on the run to
find the one-piece treasure they went
through hell to steal a map to the
ground line and now they're on the run
from every sailor in the sea they leave
this Marine base with the stolen map but
then they realize they're getting
shotted by Marines out for their blood
they hit the deck as cannons blast
through their ship nearly killing
everyone Luffy then realizes that the
man chasing them the vice admirer of the
Marines is his granddaddy shocking his
entire crew especially Nami Luffy says
that they need to fight back but Nami
tells him that they are stealing their
wind if that ship gets any closer they
are done for back on the Marine ship the
vice animal tells his men that he wants
these pirates captured alive and he
yells out to Luffy to pull over but he
refuses pissed off the man grabs a whoa
freaking Cannonball and throws it right
at Luffy's boat acting fast he expands
his rubber body to catch it and fire it
right back into the marine boat and
destroys their sails okay this group
just acted unprofessional as hell and
this is why I would have gotten out of
this situation scot-free by not being an
eager beaver like them let me explain
for a ragtag group of wannabe Pirates
they failed to do much pirating in this
situation they also had terrible
awareness skills naming the fact that
they did not see a giant Marine ship
until it was right behind them if I was
running the show I would have stationed
someone right above on the ship's Crow
Nest which is the upper part of the main
Mast of a ship that functions as a
Lookout Point enjoying the viewer up
there with the widest field of view to
look from and be able to see all types
of from coming afar because that is
the whole point of having someone up at
the Crow's Nest and if somebody got
tired all you gotta do is rotate ships
up there every three hours that way
everybody gets a nice good tan but still
you'll be able to see oh I don't know
Ships coming towards you if possible I
would have tried to leave during the
night to lessen the chances of getting
spotted by Marines which we knew were in
the area to begin with and since this
boat wasn't really registered with us
this couldn't meant we could have just
stayed hidden on the island and wait
until night with no worries of the
Marines discovering the boat until we
were ready to leave or at the very least
I would have hired a few Helping Hands
and placed them in charge of sailing our
ship while we hid below deck at least
until we're far away from this island
Port get a whole bottle of Premium
fragrance every month for 97 less money
than what you'd pay for in the store
hear me out scentbird is a fragrant
subscription that lets you choose a new
fragrance each month and they're
designed to last you the whole month for
only the price of one large premium
topping pizza their affordable
subscription plans means that you get
600 choices of the best of the best to
choose from I'm talking Gucci Prada
Versace to the very most Indian Indie
Brands like Skyler heretic confessions
of rebel and more these will let you
smell as good as us anime boys I like to
roll with the Cross River gorilla by
sanctuary and feel as pretty as a jungle
after a rainstorm very fun calculated
complexity with this one and it's gonna
make you feel upbeat in hot weather
smelling of mixed green notes and after
that I like to do a quick dash of
handsome devil by grooming Lounge for
when it's time to look dangerous and
sophisticated the spice and citrus will
lead you to Redwood and coffee sense
that will have you smelling warm and
cheeky for when you want to have a night
full of fun a 30-day Supply will allow
you to try fragrance out fully before
committing to a full-size bottle which
can cost anywhere between 150 to 300 oh
my gosh or you could just rotate
fragrances with scentbird forever don't
worry we won't tell thanks again to
scentbird for sponsoring this video use
my coupon code htba for 55 off at
Sanford that's less than eight dollars
for your first month aren't you lucky
available in the US and Canada check out
the links below and thank you to
scentbird for sponsoring this video now
back to the show vice admiral GARP here
gets so mad that he starts laughing like
a man Maniac while everyone awkwardly
watches because they don't know how to
take it and Luffy's crew manages to
disappear into the sea Luffy tells his
people that they should lay low for a
while because they can't afford to waste
time anymore they must head to the Grand
line but Nami tells them that they are
lost the crew then discusses the
elephant in the room they're being
chased by their Captain's grandparent
which is really weird Zara and the
others think it's not a big deal but
Nami is it maybe you should have shared
that information but just this a strange
smell interrupts their conversation but
the only one who could smell it is Luffy
and he tells him he can snuff something
covered in butter and it's delicious
directing his crew to the smell he
guides them out of the CMS directly into
this strange man-made Island full of
life food and Pirates are high higher
they arrive at parati Port Luffy tells
his gang that they should stop running
away and start eating away their
problems instead because he's hungry but
they don't have money anyways they head
inside meanwhile in the restaurant
kitchen this blonde shift pretty boy
Cooks the best meal of his life and
tries to serve it his boss here tells
him he can only cook what's on the menu
and that his meal is dog shite pissing
him off these two get into an argument
and the boss punishes him by making him
a waiter for the day heading out into
the dining room with this bread bowl he
then sees these customers about to fight
he tries to calm them down but they
won't listen so then he whipped out the
sick waiter moves on them knocking them
all out Luffy catches the fight from a
distance that is impressed as hell
pretty boy then takes his sexy little
bread bowl and heads straight on over to
Luffy's tip he introduces himself as
Sanji but then he catches Nami sitting
there looking all scrumptious and then
he gives her the old winky winky face
service taking their menu orders he
heads back into the kitchen while Luffy
and the crew give Nami a hard time
because hey hey somebody's got an
admirer and they enjoy their break from
all of the fighting meanwhile vice
admiral garp's men work on fixing the
ship these workers tell him that repairs
will take a day or two but cool be
bright oh gosh darn I did it again no
not that Kobe skittish Twitty face Kobe
here says that there is another Marine
ship nearby that they can call to to go
after loopy but vice admiral Garb tells
them that they are the only ones who can
handle this Mission but doesn't tell
them why he heads into his office and
makes the most devastating call he will
ever make he got a hold of the most
powerful swordsman in the world healing
screams on the other line he finally
reaches a man named mihawk slicing and
dicing then in the middle of a bloody
battle killing everybody advise
animal Garb tells mihok that he has a
job for him to do to go after a pirate
named Luffy and he tells him to not
underestimate the kid no matter what but
mihawk says just a minute and then
slices this one ship down deflecting the
bullet he mostly kills the rest of these
baddies before returning to his phone
call he accepts the vice Admiral's
Mission and gets told to bring him in
alive all the while is Kirby overhears
all of this back in the bharati port
Luffy's crew finishes their meal and the
Nami then cuts the and tells Luffy
what is the deal with his grandfather
and she gets mad at him for not telling
them this earlier and that's when Sanji
returns with the bill Luffy signs it but
quickly finds out from the owner that he
he must pay in cash or else Luffy
confidently tells him that he can add it
to his treasure tab because he is
talking to the Future King of the
Pirates he tells Chef zeph that he is on
his way to find the one-piece treasure
but zeph tells him that the only
treasure he'll find is at the bottom of
some dirty dishes and then he for his
fully takes Luffy to the kitchen and
tells him he must pay off his food debt
by working in the kitchen from now on
Sanji then comes back and tells zeph
that he's done being a waiter and
doesn't want to cook the same boring
food ever again and Luffy spots one of
sanji's dishes and tastes it loving it
and that's when Sanji leaves in Anger
later that night Luffy's crew gets drank
at the Port bar Nami tries telling these
two that Luffy Keeping a Secret is
messed up but they tell her that they
have bigger problems to deal with and
then she says she can't afford to get
caught when she's so close but she
catches herself and awkwardly leaves the
group to get more drinks Nami here seems
like she's up to something but I would
be able to figure out her true motives
based on a statistical probability using
the psychological traits of very famous
pirates in past history let me explain
this group has failed to do the one
thing that would make any team click and
that would be to learn the backstory of
their teammates at this point Luffy's
been so worried trying to recruit just
about everybody that he's forgotten to
really vet who he's actually bringing in
and in this case the wild characters
aren't the ones that I'd been worried
about but instead would want to know the
motivations behind the sweetest looking
members of our crew because the last
thing we want is a wolf in sheep's
clothing or a psycho and baddie's
clothing Nami being shady right here
doesn't seem like a big deal until we
look at the whole picture starting with
the psychological profile of how and why
somebody would want to be a pirate in
the first place yes I know she says
she's not a pirate but come on she's
with pirates contrary to how the movies
make it seem many Pirates in reality had
prior sailing backgrounds as pirateers
or were in the Navy and were also very
shrewd businessmen that were vital to
many economies and served as basically
their nation's patrons as they got in
charge with going around the world and
bring back Treasures for their countries
one such a pirate Francis Drake even got
United by Queen Elizabeth in 1581 this
means that if I was Luffy I would have
started treating these recruiting
sessions like we were recruiting for a
Fortune 500 company here's why because
if we take a look at some of the most
famous pirates ever known throughout
history Blackbeard Henry every the most
famous pirate to retire it and to not
die in battle both of these and many
more came from highly established
backgrounds and if we compare Nami to
other female pirates of the past then
this is where it only gets more
interesting unlike men women joining
pirate Crews was not common in the least
meaning to be a female pirate you had to
have some serious reasons for joining
such a life and here's where it gets
even crazier four of the most famous
female pirates in history all of them
came from respected and or well-off
families and either became Pirates to
break free from their parents
disapproval all came from a rich family
enjoined in order to avenge the people
who chased our family out from their
Homeland this means that while Zaron
usab might have joined the pirate's life
for crazy reasons Nami here likely
joined our group because she's either
running away from something or has a
massive chip on her shoulder and wants
to avenge something or someone and I
have the feeling based on previously
correlating factors that to Nami here is
way more dangerous than she looks over
at the bar she secretly asks the
bartender here that she wants to go to
the Konami Island and then he points her
to this old man and he tells her that he
can take her there at sunrise tomorrow
for a price and he could even take her
friends with her but she tells him that
she will be going there alone back at
the Marine ship Colby tells his love
hate buddy here her mepo that he heard
news from the vice admiral as he was
talking to somebody named mihawk on the
phone earlier shocked at this news he
tells Kobe that this man is not just a
man he is the greatest swordsman in the
entire world one of seven Great Pirates
Who ruled the Seas years ago the world
government made a deal with these seven
instead of trying to capture them or
kill them they were each given dirty
jobs that the good guys could not do in
order to keep the world save and in
exchange the Pirates would be allowed to
roam free in the world at the news
horrifice Kobe and her nipple tells that
while this may seem messed up this is
how the real world Works Mr I now have
Cajon is Kobe then decides to go to talk
to the vice admiral himself entering his
office he sees him eating a ton of
sticks like a man's man and he reveals
that he overheard him talking to mihawk
and then he nervously asks him why there
are different rules for different
pirates in the world as a recruit for
the Marines he signed up for this job to
protect people from Pirates and now he's
thinking of quitting because of what he
just discovered by his Admiral GARP then
boys him a glass and tells him that he
used to be like Kobe but then quickly
discovered that the world is evil and at
the same set of laws don't apply to
everyone but a marine is the only thing
standing between Warner and true Anarchy
in the world and he asks Kobe if he can
live with that because that is what
being a true Marine is all about and
inspired by this old man BS Kobe says he
can handle it and decides to stay on the
Marines back at barati Port Luffy is
busy cleaning dishes when he sees Sanji
chilling in the back they started
talking and he finds out that he is a
chef and that he has a dream to travel
to the all-blue a mythical area of the
world where you can find the best
ingredients from all four C's nobody
knows where it is but he wants to be the
one to find it Luffy gets excited and
tells him that he should follow his
dreams no matter what it takes and
that's when an injured sailor busts
through this back door he is starving
and Sanji quickly whips up some food and
that's when one of his co-workers tells
him that if Chef zeph finds out that he
is feeding someone without any money he
will get in trouble but Sanji does it
anyways minutes later the injured sailor
Chows down and tells him that he's been
drifting out in Sea for weeks and
comments that this is the best meal he's
ever had in his life and Luffy gets
really impressed by Sanji and he tells
him that he should join their crew to
help feed them while they go after the
one-piece treasure and that's when the
sailor's eyes go wide and he reveals
that he was actually a part of a huge 50
ship team that were looking for the
one-piece treasure themselves but once
they got to the grad line they lost all
5 000 of their men and he is the only
Survivor he begs Luffy to not go there
no matter what because he will never
make it out of there alive nami's crude
chills over some drinks and Zoro can
tell that she is hiding something they
play a drinking game to find out more
about each other and reason for joining
the crew in its blah blah blah is not
important but across from them oosava
gets drunk and talks a good game in
front of these pirate baddies but then
this one guy sitting next to him asks
him if he's the captain and usop gets
uncomfortable and says that a man is
named Luffy is their Captain intrigued
the man asks which one of them is Luffy
but none of them tell him anything Zoro
then looks at him dead in the eyes and
says that he knows who he is dracul
mihawk he reveals that he is his biggest
fan and it's because of him that he
wanted to become the world's greatest
swordsman and it's because of mihawk's
skill that he must Now kill him Zorro
challenges the world's greatest killer
right now to a duel tomorrow morning
shocking Nami and USA back in the
kitchen Luffy catches Chef zeph passing
by in the kitchen and gives him for
not letting Sanji follow his dreams and
accidentally tells him that Sanji fed a
homeless customer earlier for free at
the new saw brushes in and tells him
that they need him to come back to the
boat as soon as possible at their boat
Luffy finds out that his granddad sent a
high profile assassin one of the seven
Warlords of the sea to kill him but
first Zorro is going to fight him
tomorrow morning moving called Zorro
crazy but says he can't stop him he
can't step in his way to achieve his
dream Nami thinks zoru is crazy and she
is shocked that Luffy's dead serious
about everybody following their dreams
including silly or serious ones Nami
begged him not to do it because he is
her friend but Zorro tells you that
earlier when she was trying to act tough
she said she didn't have any friends and
this pisses her off and she walks away
early in the next morning Nami steals
the map to the Grand line and heads out
to meet her ride that is going to take
her to the kanobi islands but at the
last minute she has a change of heart
and goes to link back up with her crew
Justin in time to see Zoro meet up with
mihawk getting ready for the duel he
wipes out his mighty tiny sword
confusing Zara and proving to everybody
that Size Doesn't Matter at least when
you're mihawk and he tells Zoro that he
isn't worthy of his big sword all right
all right all right I know I know it
seems like we just can't get out of this
situation that I would have unscrewed Us
by screwing everyone else let me explain
me Hawk here is the world's most
deadliest swordsman and the goal of
Zorro and he has now robbed everybody
else into it thanks dude since Zara is
such big on Hunter this means he's more
of a liability than an asset because he
will either screw us over or get in our
way which means he's willing to take
time out of our plans to go to the Grand
line in order to reach his goal we do
not need that and we have until
morning before mihawk shows up again
this is why if I was Luffy with the help
of zeph and our crew I would make two
Luffy dummy dolls for the purpose that
one doll would be escorted by Nami while
the second doll would be escorted by
Zoro both of them would head into
opposite directions on boats and this
was would confuse mihawk on which
direction we went for starters and I
would tell Nami that I would catch up
with her later at a different point
however the moment her and Zara's both
left Port I would go and recruit Sanji
to be on my crew I would then take my
boat in a third unknown Direction by
either of them with the purposes of
circling back onto the route to the
Grand lie and get there without an army
or sorrow yes I'm lying to them but
again it would likely increase our
chances of being able to get away pissed
off Zoro whipped out his swords and
charges at me Hawk slamming against his
tiny weapon but he easily blows Zorro
back making him realize that he is
clearly outmatched and he tells him that
he's strong but fighting isn't about
strength and he quickly manages to
lightly stabs or shocking him and mihawk
asks him why doesn't he retreat but he
tells me Hawk that he cat or his dream
will be lost forever miog tells him that
he's impressed with his bravery and that
he will honor his dream by killing him
with his big boy sword taking it out of
the sheath revealing a giant sword that
has put fear into everybody across seas
and Zoro sets up his three sword
technique and charges mihawk a final
time both clash swords but Zoro realizes
that his have been broken and he has
officially been defeated in combat and
mihawk says that he should quit but
Zorro tells him that a samurai can never
surrender until he is forced to and is
prepared to die mihawk then fulfills his
wishes and Strikes him down and
everybody screams they rushed to check
on it but I then mihawk strike actually
didn't kill him intrigued mihawk asks
Luffy what his true goal in life is and
Luffy tells him that he wants to reach
the grand life find the one-piece
treasure and become the king of the
Pirates impressed mihawk tells him that
the world could use a few more wild
cards and says that he will leave him to
his mission and he also tells Zoro that
he is a worthy fighter and that he
should come find him when he gets
stronger someday they quickly take Zorro
back to their boat and Nami tells Luffy
to go find a doctor at the restaurant
and there he asks Chef sep if he knows
any doctors near here but he tells him
that the closest ones are a few days
away by boat but he can help instead
reaching back Chef Zev pulls out some
really cool MacGyver combining fish
skin and stitches any patches zoro's
wounds and tells him that the fish
scales will help heal the wounds faster
but warns them that he's lost a lot of
blood that he might not make it through
the night this is why they should keep
talking to him in order to keep him in
this world World Nami gets pissed at
Luffy that he let Zorro pull this stupid
stunt but he tells her that he had to
follow his dreams and she tells him that
in real life not everybody gets to
follow their dreams later mihawk travels
back to vice admiral garb's boat and
tells him that he let Luffy go and the
vice admiral gets pissed but mihog says
that he wants to see what happens when
his grandson reaches the grand line
because he thinks he might just do it
just outside Kobe hears all of this and
he's shocked and mihawk leaves the
office while Vice and roggarp loses his
he then calls in Kobe and
apologizes for not telling him this
information sooner and reveals to him
his true goal he actually wants to save
Luffy and to make him not turn into a
pirate the Kobe tells him they're based
on his interaction with him when they
first met he was born to be a pirate and
that's when an idea suddenly strikes
Vice and regard and he tells Kobe to
call a marine meeting as soon as
possible with all the men lined up
outside he announces to everybody and
everyone that their mission has now
changed he finally realizes that Luffy
Will Never Surrender which means they
must now fight dirty in order to bring
them to justice the next day the most
horrifying creatures of the sea arrive
at bharati Port entering the restaurant
they threaten everybody already inside
and say that no one can they introduced
themselves as fishmen and meet with chef
zeph and he cautiously approaches them
this fish man says that his name is
arlong and that he owns the East blue
sea he's come to find somebody named
Luffy because he has something very
important that belongs to him Chef Zep
says that he doesn't know about this
person but arlong can tell he's lying
and he warns him that if he doesn't
bring him in soon he will kill everyone
here meanwhile Nami listens in and
overhears all of this she then runs back
to Luffy's boat and tells everybody the
news she tells them that they should
leave this place now but Luffy tells him
that they must stay in Fight to help
sanji's people since he helped them and
Luffy tells an army to stay on the ship
and guard the map okay well in my team
like we're screwed I would have thought
all of our problems with our lung with a
little bit of cooking grease let me
explain arlong is a member of the arlong
Pirates who's got the highest bounty in
the East blue but at this point he
doesn't know where we are exactly which
is why he is holding everyone here
hostage he wants us to come to and is
relying on our Humanity to bait us since
we have the advantage of time on our
side I would first order my crew to go
and destroy the most crucial elements of
their boat and we'll get our getaway
vote ready for what's about to happen
next you'll see that despite the unclear
timeline wherein this kitchen has a
gas-lit stove which means that a gas
line is present back then it would have
also likely been that places with gas
stoves had high pressure regulators
installed within the gas system this is
a valve that automatically cuts off the
flow of gas and when it reaches a
certain pressure it is designed to
direct only the amount of gas into the
pipes that the load device can take this
is why after disabling our Long's boat I
would sneak Sanji into the kitchen
through the side entrance that the
hungry sailing came through right before
and within switch on the gas and allow
the gas from all the stoves to
accumulate over the burner the lack of a
gas pressure regulator means a large
amount of gas would easily diffuse into
the air around the entire kitchen as
soon as this is a professional kitchen
this means that grease cooking oil
alcohol will be present everywhere and
heavy amount all of these are highly
combustible the saturation of excess gas
from multiple Strokes means that after
two minutes this place will be a fire
hazard while this was taking place I
would instruct one of us to meet our
long in the restaurant from the front
and from there would lure him into the
kitchen saying we had the map there due
to his lack of faith in humans and him
thinking we're not as smart or strong as
him he would likely think we're not
capable of tricking him I would follow
us into the kitchen with no problem I
would then head out of the back of the
kitchen and have one of our crews light
aflame this would set up a highly
combustible explosion one full of fire
pressure and death and at this point
either our lung would have been dead or
the very least injured long enough to
where we could run away with the map all
because he underestimated us his enemy
back at the restaurant our Long's fish
people led to these humans in on their
full plan they tell them that they are
done being second-class citizens of the
world and make a speech about wanting to
be treated as equals for once if they
don't they will destroy the world in
order to make it happen Luffy then busts
into front are long and he asks them how
he tracked them down and Arlon takes out
the head of one of his old enemies buggy
the clown and this idiot clown reveals
to Luffy that one of his ears was hiding
in his head this whole time oh that's so
gross and he's overheard their entire
plan but then he yaps too much so the
Fishman put him back in this bag our
long tells Luffy that he wants the grand
line map but Luffy says Nah and he'll
fight him for it instead and that's when
Chef zeph shoots arlung in the back
pissing them all off as they start a
beat down on everybody Sanji rushes in
to save his boss knocking this guy down
with his fancy moves but he quietly gets
knocked back by their super strength
Luffy reacts quick and fires off his gum
gum pistol but Arlan quickly catches it
and throws him back Luffy goes in for a
second series of strikes but he quickly
finds out that they are too powerful for
them and he violently gets thrown out of
the restaurant and gets beaten down
again and again getting thrown onto this
boat trying to give up a final time
Arlon quickly splashes sea water on is
one weakness now helpless he picks up
Luffy like a rag doll it is about her
and his neck but that's when Nami shows
up and says that she has what he wants
the map to the Grand line and she tells
Luffy and everybody that she's actually
been a part of the Fish Man pirate and
has been for years Luffy doesn't believe
her but she tells him that he believes
only what she wants him to believe and
that this is his greatest weakness he
believes in everybody our long is about
to kill him for good when Nami stops him
and tells him to let the sea do its
Dirty Work smiling our lung drops Luffy
into the water and they struggles to
breathe while Nami in the Fishman
Pirates leave the area but at the last
minute Sanji comes to his rescue and
barely saves his life and they think of
what to do next later at the restaurant
Sanji returns to start cleaning up the
place but that's when Chef zeph comes in
and tells him that he's too good to work
here any longer and Sanji calls him
crazy but zip warned him that he has a
dream that he should go after and not
end up like him an overweight old pirate
whose his leg because hey he never
fulfilled his dream and also that Sanji
has never shut up about going after his
goal and now it's starting to get really
annoying pissing Sanji up he angrily
tells chef chef that he'll do as he
wishes then and storms out of the
restaurant a little later Zorro finally
wakes up and Luffy and him agree to help
both of them go after their dreams and
by still being come the best semen Bros
usab joins in on the fun and with some
team spirit Luffy suggests that they
should first go and figure out what's
going on with the Nami before they head
to the Grand line and everybody agrees
preparing to set sail Sanji then joins
them last minute as their cook and they
set sail to go save Nami but then zanji
has a really sweet moment to his father
figures really killed him but it's not
important moving on Luffy tells
everybody that he knows somebody who
knows where Nami is and takes out buggy
the clown revealing that he stole him
from the Fishman earlier and he can lead
them to her location a little while
later with the help of this freaky clown
usab spots landed the distance and they
finally reach the Konomi Islands home to
the arlong Pirates meanwhile at our long
perk Nami is sent to go meet him and she
gives him the map to the Grand line and
he thanks her for helping to map out all
of the locations of the Marines Pirates
everybody around the Seas and he tells
her that with his Fishman he will soon
rule the sea and he will take her with
him he then sends her off on another job
while his team gets ready to go to the
Grand line telling her to go collect
payment from a town nearby that owes
them money the same town that she grew
up in Cocoa Village where she asks if
someone else can do it but our long
tells her that only a human can and he
forces her to go nearby Luffy's crew
investigates these strange Island
looking for Nami and come across this
destroyed Village they soon read a group
of villagers stressing about not having
enough money to pay our long my what
convenient timing and that's when Nami
enters the village as well and demands
payment these people call Nami a traitor
to her own people and this girl here
tells her that she has a lot of nerve
showing up when everyone hates her for
what she did and that she leaves in
anger and Louvre in the distance sees
this Nami collects this town's payment
and tells them to find more money soon
or else they'll be in trouble and that's
when she spots Luffy and tells them to
leave her alone because this is where
she belongs louvi thinks she needs their
help but Nami tells him to stop trying
to save everybody and storms off Sanji
thinks something else must be going on
Zorro tells him that she clearly wants
them to leave but he tells Zorro that
women never say what they mean his
actual words and that's when Ladies Man
Luffy agrees with Sanji and as eyes that
they should visit that girl that Nami
was talking to because she seemed to
know her getting directions from one of
the locals they find her house I managed
to convince her to spill the beans on
NAMI in exchange for having Sanji
cooking her the best meal of her life
back in barati Port the Marines finally
arrived and have a word with Chef Seth
about Luffy's whereabouts because they
know he was here Chef Zev tells him that
he doesn't know anything and offers him
a free steak dinner instead and they
still have a grand conversation and
that's one vice admiral cop signals for
Kobe and helmhepo to leave and tells
Chef zeph that he knows everybody saw
Luffy leave this town and he needs to
find him before it's too late meanwhile
back on Konomi Island sanji's
deliciousness convinces the girl to
start talking and she gives a little
backstory about her and Nami and she
reveals that they are sisters and that
their mother was killed by all along
when they were kids and then Nami went
to join Arlo's crew for some strange
reason and since then they barely spoken
to each other the end Luffy then gets up
to get some fresh air because he can't
believe what he's hearing Zorro joins
him and they both agree that there must
be something more to this story because
they believe deep down Nami is a goody
goody a little later at our long space
they have a party to celebrate and
that's when Nami reports back with funds
from Coco Village and then she tries to
talk to arlong about their deal that she
made within years ago but then these
marines interrupt the party Captain
nezumi here kills arlong that he's here
for another and check it because they've
been getting reports from the Navy that
him and his pirate crew had been making
an awful lot of noise on these islands
and Ireland tries to pay him the
standard bribe but nezumi tells him that
the price has now gone up because it's
getting harder and harder to cover their
pirate asses annoyed he tells the
Marines to finish this discussion in his
office and signals for Nami to join them
inside the marines tell him that they
can't afford to help our log if they
don't increase their price and Arlo
didn't agrees to their demands
surprising them and they gave him a
backhanded compliment saying for a
Fishman he's pretty smart and oh Boyle
this pisses him off and he intimidates
these marines so much they give him back
the extra money and agree to their old
deal before running away nearby Nami is
listening in from the outside and then
comes in and she tells our love that she
finally has what what he wants and he
can finally fulfill their deal after all
these years she tells him that she
finally has 100 million Barry to buy out
her Village shocking him he tells her to
bring the money to him by sunrise and he
will let her and her entire Village go
forever leaving he then tells one of his
minions to go bring back the dirty
Marines bhagavarotti
get drinks while they wait for their
bikes Admiral carp to finish his food
their Kobe reveals to him a shocking
secret Luffy is their Vice Admiral's
grandson shocking helmepo and he now
says it makes sense why their boss was
going after such a small Time Pirate the
bar tend to hear the Nova hears them it
says that he knows when Luffy and his
crew went and that he can tell them for
a small fee meanwhile inside the
restaurant Chef zeph tells ice animal
GARP that Luffy reminds him of gold
Roger the famous pirate who hid the
one-piece treasure 20 years ago vice
admiral car the confines and shifts if
and tells him that he doesn't want his
grandkid to end up like gold rather and
die the worst way possible and that's
when Kobe comes in and tells him that
they know where Luffy went and then the
Marines then head off to the Kanobe Isle
Nami goes to dig out her treasure and
that's when her friend catches her and
normally tries to explain herself but
her friend doesn't listen and slams the
chest open discovering a bunch of
treasure shocked Nami explains to her
that she made a deal with along when
they were kids and that she would work
for him and has been trying to buy their
Village from him and she's now saved up
100 million Berry and with it she can
buy everyone's freedom and that's when
her friend who's actually her sister by
the way she realizes that she's been a
dick to Nami for years and now feels bad
and that's when captain nezumi and his
men show up they announced that they are
confiscated the 100 million buried
treasure that's nami's got but that's
when Nami realizes that she never told
them how much was in this chest and she
knows that our long set her up they hold
her down and steal everything that she
has and that's when she cries and tries
go after them telling her sister they
now are long will try to kill everybody
as punishment soon running out of breath
she collapses in sadness and anger and
then she starts to try to remove her
Fishman tattoo but that's when Luffy
reaches her and tells her that he's here
to help if she needs it breaking down
she finally asks him for help and he
gives her his trusty hat and he tells
her that they'll get to work and save
everybody and that's when his crew shows
up as well and they get ready for combat
and then they hear gunshots and piercing
screams in the distance going to check
it out they see part of nami's Village
burning in the distance and they rush to
go and stop it arriving at the Village
they realize it's too late and see part
of the village in shambles they then run
into her sister who's nojiko by the way
and she tells him that she's told the
villagers what to Nami really did and
everybody agrees to forgive her I would
say so she had 100 million Berry the
villagers now want to fight our long and
are now done with being cowards
reluctantly not only agrees to let them
fight alongside her and Luffy tells them
that while might not seem like arlong
has any weakness everybody has a
weakness and he will know it when he
sees it motivating everybody to get
ready for the fight of their lives
meanwhile on the Marine ship captain
nezumi reaches by Samuel guard Midway
but Vice and Mugabe asks him why so much
pirate activity what has been happening
around Kenobi Islands says it's under
their control but that's what Captain
nuzumi tries to shift the blame and says
that her new powerful pirate has entered
the area and has been slaughtering
everybody that he's sees and swears that
he wears a straw hat cover nearby then
talks back and says that Luffy would
never hurt anyone innocent and vice
admiral GARP agrees and thinks Something
Fishy is going on he then relieves
captain nezumi of his duties on Konomi
islands that he will handle it from here
back on Kenobi Island Luffy's group
blasts through arlong's headquarters
smoke bombs go off everywhere and Nami
tells that our long is in the bathroom
and takes her and Luffy to him while the
rest of the crew gets ready to stop
these bad guys right now anusob runs
like a little girl as he gets chased by
this drinking Fishman this might look
like a badass approach but in reality
this was so stupid it makes no sense why
these guys decided to go in with a pack
the bad guys already destroyed the
village and went home to recharge there
was absolutely no need to run into this
situation head first and as mentioned
our long is strong but way too confident
and thinks too low of us and that is why
his guard will be down they could have
approached this situation in a few ways
if Louie wanted to keep our long busy he
could have at least coordinated with the
townsfolk for them to bring in alcohol
during this battle they could have used
it to try and burn down the headquarters
entirely or they could have done a more
stealthy way and could have severely
injured the enemies by looking to poison
their water supply either the pool
itself or more realistically identifying
the source of their alcohol seller
fishmen need water in order to enhance
their powers so finding a way to
leverage their greatest strength I'd
turn it into a weakness should have at
least been considered as a possible
battle plan in advance and another more
volatile approach could have been for
Nami to look for any other communication
device that she possessed and she could
have used that to call but Vice animal
grab I know I know hear me out if this
Village was so important to her that she
should have been willing to destroy
arlong in every way possible and let's
be honest she never would have left her
Village again if arlog was alive so
finding a way to kill him was really the
only way she could make a move the
Marines already looking for them or at
least Luffy so calling them means they
would have been there within the day
inside the map room Nami finds the map
but that's when Arlon cuts her off with
his Lethal Weapon and he tells her that
his Grand bad guy planned to take back
what the humans took from his kind using
the very map the Nami made for him and
then he's going to go to the credit line
and blah blah blah blah blah don't care
but Arlen compliments on using NAMI so
well for his own game Luffy gets Furious
and bites on his sword breaking it and
he signals for Nami to escape meanwhile
outside usab hides from this Fishman
chasing him and he plays dead tricking
this guy and uses that exact moment to
fire some hot sauce bullets and uses his
special attack exploding star on this
bad guy blowing his bottle of alcohol up
along with him winning the battle but
with nobody around to see it so he's
kind of sad back inside our Long Park
Sanji and Zoro get tired of fighting
buggy here then says that if they put
his body back on him he can help them
desperate they do what he says and the
minute he gets his body back he freaking
leaves idiots this final Fishman enters
the area and is shocked that all of his
fish Brothers have died and then he gets
ready to kick these two's asses using
Fishman karate he charges at them and
surprise jumps on Sanji while Zorro
tries to help him inside the map room
Luffy continues to try his best but he
can't beat him no matter what he does he
then has an idea and realizes that he is
in the most important room in the
building and he tells Arlo that he
wouldn't be anything without an army and
starts destroying the support pillar our
lung realizes that he's trying to
destroy all that Nami has helped him
build and he tries to stop him beating
him up non-stop but Luffy summons his
last strength breaking the entire room
as everything starts shaking down
outside Sanji gets tired of getting his
ass kicked and finally whips out his
signature move sending this Fishman back
badly injured before finishing him off
and then saves the day and that's when
Nami comes out running and the building
is shaking and then Sanji is ready to be
the man to hold Nami in his arms and air
well he gets denied and she tells them
that Lutheran airlock are still fighting
inside meanwhile Luffy uses his final
gum gum gaggling move on arlong and
finish him off with his gum gum battle
ax slamming our lung down and since the
entire building crashing above them
everyone holds their breath but Luffy
survives rising up they link back up and
appreciate each other and blah blah blah
later that night though they celebrate
hikoko Village and that's when their
celebration is cut short by Marines
fights Admiral GARP shows up and tells
them that they're under arrest and Kobe
tries to back him up but the vice
admiral doesn't listen he tells his
grandson Luffy that he's tried to make a
marine but he realizes that he will
always choose to be a stupid child he
demands Luffy to hand over the map but
he says no and Grandpa's had enough and
starts punching Luffy and tells him he's
going to treat him like a pirate from
now on Luffy is shocked and tells his
granddad that he doesn't want to fight
him but it's too late he beats up Luffy
time and time again and proves he's much
stronger than he is and he tells him
that he doesn't know how dangerous the
grand line is and that he is not ready
but Luffy says that he's not going to
give up no matter what happens and then
he starts chuckling just like the man
who hid the one-piece treasure gold
Roger vice admiral GARP sees that he
truly is a pirate and reveals to him
that this was all a test he signals for
his men to stop chasing him and to go
after our Long's remaining Pirates and
then Captain nezmi tries to arrest Luffy
but gets knocked out and the vice
admiral tells Luffy that he knew he
wouldn't change his mind but he wanted
to make sure he knew who he really was
and he congratulate Luffy and tells him
that he's on his own now the next day
everybody makes up including Nami and
her sister nojika blah blah blah and
porn but Kobe pays Luffy a visit and
hands him his own wanted poster making
him officially a badass pirate and Luffy
gets happy and the two say goodbye to
each other and he heads back to his crew
to show him the good news and they
realize that now more Pirates will start
to hunt them down on their way to the
Grand mine and they get ready for what's
to come they pick up this barrel and
then Proclaim all of their dreams
together a good party be Hardies and
they all vowed to help each other reach
their dreams together not realizing that
all the new horrifying enemies await
thank you Sandberg for sponsoring
today's video now be sure to click the
link down below in order to use my code
for a discount but what do you guys
think about the video let us know what
you like about it and what you didn't
like about it don't forget to like
subscribe and leave a thumbs up down
below and as always check out our how to
be playlist